il a commis l'irréparable que personne
ne peut se mettre à à sa place parce que
quelque chose avec lequel il vit en
permanence c'est irrémédiable ce qu'il a
[Musique]
commis
je suis la maman de
Philippe je vous en supplie
rendez-lemoi c'est irrémédiable ce qu'il
a commis pour moi c'est un
[__] il y a eu des incidces qui qui
ont qui ont fait que d'ailleurs pour
c'est pourquoi la police s'est adressé à
moi cet homme n'est pas un tueur je ne
vois pas
retuer il prend conscience de son échec
il est une image un symbole une un
modèle un repoussoir il a dit on a voulu
faire de moi un superhéros mais je ne
suis qu'un pauvre
type
1976 la France a peur un petit garçon de
8 ans a été enlevé à la sortie de
l'école par un homme qui voulait
soutirer de l'argent à sa
famille cet enfant s'appelait Philippe
Bertron son ravisseur Patrick Henry l'a
tué un an plus tard l'homme échappe à la
peine de mort il est c de la réclusion
criminelle à
perpétuité patck h va rest 25 ans en
prison et devenir malgré lui un
emblème celui des longues peines de la
réinsertion celui de
l'échec avec Imen guali nous avons
décidé de retrouver les protagonistes de
l'affaire Patrick Henry et d'analyser
avec eux les répercussions de ce dossier
hors
norme c'est un peu une condamnation
symbolique 4 ans de prison ferme pour
avoir transporté en voiture 10 kg de
hachich le meurtre P du petit Philippe
Bertrand devra également payer une
amende de 20000 € de toute façon Patrick
Henry doit purger une peine de réclusion
à perpétuité mais la justice a quand
même eu la main
lourde 30 janvier
1976 il est midi Philippe Bertrand un
garçon de 8 ans sort de l'école à
3 à midi 200 le téléphone sonne chez ses
parents sa maman décroche au bout du fil
un homme il a enlevé Philippe il veut de
l'argent beaucoup d'argent un million de
francs la famille Bertrand prévient
aussitôt la police c'est la péj de reins
qui prend
l'enquête la façon dont les gens nous
raconaient comment il sentait cette
disparition du petit Philippe Bertrand
nous a fait quand même prendre l'affaire
très au
sérieux la police recherche des témoins
de l'enlèvement et interroge les proches
le domicile de la famille Bertrand est
placée sur
écoute
18h16 le téléphone sonne à nouveau c'est
le ravissur les policiers demandent à
Monsieur Bertrand de prolonger l'appel
le plus longtemps possible au bout de 7
minutes les services techniques chargés
des téléphones avait repéré l'endroit
d'où partait la communication
téléphonique à savoir une cabine de
briviande toutes les équipes foncent
vers la cabine avec ordre de ne pas
intervenir les policiers veulent prendre
leur avisseur en filature pour qu'il les
mènent jusqu'à l'enfant il faut faire
vite l'homme est toujours en
ligne
18h28 une première équipe de policiers
arrive enfin en vue de la cabine la
voiture se garde discrètement le piège
est tendu le ravisseur n'est qu'à
quelques mètres tout le monde était en
place tous les acteurs quand brutalement
est arrivé une une estafhette de
gendarmerie avec deux gendarmes à bord
qui faisaient fonctionner leur girophare
l'individu qui était dans la cabine a
immédiatement sauté dans le ravin qui se
trouve à côté traversé un ruisseau et a
disparu dans le
noir les gendarmes viennent de faire une
énorme bourde leur ravisseur s'est
envolé et avec lui les espoirs de
retrouver le petit
Philippe la vie de l'enfant est en
danger les hommes de l'Office central de
répression du banditisme sont appelés en
renfort
[Musique]
Charles Pellegrini vous arrivez dans
cette enquête après un un gros raté
quelle est l'ambiance les gendarmes un
peu traumatisés par ce qui s'est passé
se mettent un peu en retraint et et là
tout le monde est quand même un
peu un peu mal à l'aise quelles sont les
les priorités bah la priorité c'est de
retrouver l'enfant c'est à la fois
simple et compliqué qu'est-ce qu'on fait
dans une enquête comme ça on interroge
tout le monde
évidemment on on on met de côté tous les
ragots et les racontards d'une ville de
province ah mais oui ça allait pas dans
le couple mais il y avait des problèmes
d'argent nous on cherche qui qui peut
avoir qui connaissait le gosse qui va le
chercher et donc on est quand même
encore un peu dans le bleu sur la
personnalité du
ravisseur l'affaire de la cabine
téléphonique nous aura permis de voir
qu'il s'agissait d'un homme assez jeune
puisqu'il avait quand même dévalé une
pente et puis traversé assz rapidement
le ruisseau on retenait aussi dans cette
opération que le gars connaissait bien
d'ailleurs le coin parce qu'il avait
vite disparu d'un autre côté être resté
aussi longtemps au téléphone démontrer
une certaine maladresse si vous voulez
et ce que n'aurait pas fait
professionnel ou des des professionnels
de du
kidnapping un profil se dessine mais
toujours aucune piste malgré des
fouilles minutieuses l'enfant reste
introuvable la maman du petit Philippe
lance un appel je suis la maman de
Philippe je vous en supplie
rendez-lemoi ne nous laissez plus
souffrir
[Musique]
encore 3 jours plus tard le ravisseur se
manifeste enfin un gant de l'enfant est
déposé dans la boîte aux lettres d'un
proche de la famille à l'intérieur ses
instructions les parents PHPP doiv
réunir 1 million de francs en grosse
coupure pour remettre la rançon Monsieur
Bertrand doit suivre un itinéraire
imposé direction Brienne le château à 40
km de 3 la famille a prévenu la police
les enquêteurs suivent le père de
loin c'est ici au pied du panneau de pin
que le Gérald bertr le père du petit
Philippe a trouvé une botte appartenant
à son fils dans la se trouvait un
message lui demandant de suivre les
instructions qui devaent l'amener au
village suivant où il trouverait un
autre indice c'était le début du jeu de
piste un jeu de piste macabre à chaque
relais Gérald Bertrand découvre un
vêtement de son fils après 2 he de route
dernière étape le parking d'un
restaurant Monsieur Bertrand dépose
l'argent et repart vers
3 les enquêteurs restent en planque
l'œil rivé sur la ronçon
de son côté le commissaire Bertrand
investit le restaurant leur R avisseur
est peut-être à l'intérieur le patron
lui signale qu'un client est en train de
partir au volant d'une déesse blanche
immédiatement je chargeis une équipe
d'un fonctionnaire de partir derrière
cette voiture et d'interpeller
l'individu la DESS est trop rapide et
sèe les policiers mais ils ont le temps
de relever son immatriculation elle
appartient à un certain Patrick Henri
un jeune homme de 23 ans un ami de la
famille
Bertrand le lendemain matin les
policiers l'interpellent chez lui à 3
ils sont persuadés de tenir le
coupable Patrick Henry est placé en
garde à vue il parle pas il est retort
il se défend pied à pied il ni même
quasiment l'évidence il a une
explication à tout c'est pas c'est pas
lui et voilà pas d'aveux dé charges
insuffisantes après 48 heures de garde à
vue Patrick Henry est
[Musique]
libéré Nicole vous êtes la sœur de
Patrick Henry il a été libéré vous êtes
soulagé j'imagine à ce moment-là benah
oui parce que tout à fait parce que bon
B donc donc il est il est repassé à la
maison il dit mais c'est pas possible
pourquoi qu'ils m'ont gardé en garde à
vue et tout mais je dis attends attends
tout le monde peut faire des erreurs
t'inquiète pas moi ce qu'était logique
he moi je je le soutenais on a jamais
jamais jamais soupçonné un seul instant
un seul instant que c'est que ça pouvait
être lui c'était pas possible c'était
pas possible parlez-nous de lui à
l'époque quel genre de jeune homme
c'était bah quel genre de jeune homme
bon nous avons déjà 9 ans de différence
donc pour moi c'était
vraiment c'est bon c'était mon petit
frère certes mais c'était ma mon
baigneur mon mon fils c'était tout et
donc il était toujours gentil il
travaillait bien à l'école pu bon quand
il est arrivé ce DRAM là ben voilà c'est
c'est j'en reviens toujours
pas les jours suivants Patrick mène une
vie normale au nombreux journalistes
venus l'interviewer il répète la même
chose il est innocent il y a eu
desincidces qui qui ont qui ont fait que
d'ailleurs c'est pourquoi la police
s'est adressée à
moi c'est les
coïncidenceces retour à la case départ
les policiers n'ont plus aucune piste
jusqu'à ce témoignage
anonyme l'homme qu' disait être Patrick
Henry et que les journaux présentés à la
télévision et dans la presse écrite
était un garçon qui avait été vu dans
une rue de TR devant une pension de
famille
lescharmis les enquêteurs foncent sur
place il présentent une photo du suspect
au gérant le patron dit mais oui ce
garçon je le connais mais il ne s'agit
pas de Patrick Henry il s'agit à
Monsieur van dermèche à qui j'ai loué
l'appartement qui se trouve derrière et
qui a une entrée indépendante d'ailleurs
il est ici en ce
moment les policiers se ruent dans la
chambre et arrêtent Patrick Henry qui
tente de
s'enfuir lorsqu'il fouille le deux
pièces loué par le jeune
homme sous le lit ils ont vu comme un
tapis roulé et Patrick Henry qui était à
côté de d'un inspecteur me noté a dit
ben c'est
l'enfant le petit Philippe Bertrand est
mort cette fois Patrick Henry ne peut
plus nier c'est bien lui qui l'a enlevé
et qui l'a
tué il l'a étranglé le lendemain de son
enlèvement les pleurs de l'enfant
réclamant ses parents lui ont fait
perdre la tête dit-il il ne voulait pas
le tuer il n'a rien prémédité quant à
son mobile il est
sordide simplement il dit qu'il avait
besoin d'argent et que donc il a enlevé
l'argent l'enfant pour l'argent s'il
avait pas cet enfant mort c'est unee
banalité cerurante un mec unminable
comme petit malfraat même pas malfraat
petit délinquant de de de bac à sable
qui a besoin d'argent il a pas d'idée il
va pas braquer une banque il va pas
faire quoi que ce soit il va simplement
enlever un gosse parce qu'il a dû voir
ça quelque part sans penser que ça
allait mal se terminer des aveux
terribles insoutenables pour la famille
Bertron mais aussi un coup de Massu pour
les proches de Patrick Henry ah ben je
pouvais pas le croire encore je ne
pouvais pas le
croire si si on avait été encore dans
une famille où où on manquait de de tout
qu'on était à l'abandon mais c'était pas
le cas on était aimé de nos
parents même même si eux ils avaient
peut-être des soucis des problèmes
d'argent ou quoi on on en a jamais su
nous on a toujours été protégé on a
jamais manqué de rien jamais jamais
jamais jamais jamais on était tellement
heureux chez chez Papa et Maman et tout
que jamais jamais j'aurais pu personne
personne du reste aurait pu imaginer
comprendre ce qui a pu lui passer par la
tête ah bah voilà voilà qu'est-ce qu' a
pu lui passer par la tête ses aveux sont
terribles mais vous vous le soutenez
quand même ben c'est évident c'est
évident hein pas le droit de de
l'abandonner le 20 février
1976 3 jours après la découverte du
corps les obsèque du petit Philippe
Bertrand rassemble des centaines de
personnes devant l'église de
pontste-marie à 3 la France entière suit
les funérailles à la télévision le crime
de Patrick Henry provoque colère et
indignation personne ne veut assurer la
défense du meurtrier un avocat va
finalement
accepter j'ai reçu des lettres d'injure
des coups de téléphone permanents euh
des menaces de tous les côtés sur
moi-même sur mes enfants c'est c'est
vous dire que c'était quand même quelque
chose de très très particulier monsieur
Bouquillon c'est un grand-père qui vous
cause là écoutez-moi ce que jeis vous
dire hein ne défendez pas un bandit ne
défendez pas un bandit et tous ces gens
c'était des justiciers qui voulaient la
peau de Patrick Henry à ce moment-là
c'est précisément c'est ce qui m'a en
réalité incité à dire non j'assurerai ta
défense Patrick Henry risque la peine
capitale l'avocat sait qu'il va avoir
besoin d'aide il contacte Robert
badinterre un pénaliste déjà célèbre
pour son combat contre la la peine de
mort va-t-il accepter de défendre
Patrick Henry je m'étais
juré que tout accusé qui risquerait sa
tête et qui demanderait de le défendre
quel que soit le crime je le défendrai
j'ai donc répondu oui tout de suite la
tâche s'annonce colossal pour les deux
avocats rien dans son parcours n'excuse
ou n'atténue le crime abject de
sa
personnalité
était sans relief sans intérêt il n'y
avait rien dans son passé auquel
s'accrochait cétait pas une victime de
la société
c'était comme ça un jeune homme terne
Fallot sans aucun rapport avec son crime
cette identité même le
rendait peut-être plus plus odieux il
était celui que l'on pouvait rencontrer
partout
le 18 janvier
1977 presque 1 an après la mort du petit
Philippe le procès de Patrick Henry
s'ouvre à TR l'accusé cristallise la
haine et le désir de vengeance seul un
miracle peut lui éviter la
guillotine avec une plaidoirie qui va
marquer l'histoire Robert Badinter prend
la
parole vous avez vous et vous seul à
cette minute et oubliez tout ce qui vous
entoure vous avez seul le droit de VI de
mort sur
quelqu'un à croire que quand on aura C
guidé un criminel qu' en aura fini avec
le crime alors que ce n'est pas vrai à
cet égard dites-vous bien si vous le
coupez en deux et bien ça dis a rien ni
[Musique]
personne après 1h et demi de délibéré
les jurés reviennent dans la salle
d'audience Patrick Henry est déclaré
coupable d'enlèvement coupable de
séquestration et coupable de meurtre à
la surprise générale il échappe à la
peine de mort Patrick Henry est condamné
à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité ça a été un tolé général des
cris des hurlements à mort les jue des
salots et cetera et cetera ça a été un
toé mais personne n'avait approuvé le
verdict Patrick Henry a sauvé sa tête
une stupéfaction pour tout le monde y
compris pour sa
famille Nicole lorsque le verdict tombe
vous y croyez à ce que vous
entendez non honnêtement non et il y
avait une personne derrière moi que je
ne connaissais pas qui qui m'avait
préparé un petit papier pour me soutenir
parce que pensant elle aussi elle
pensait que il allait êre condamné à
mort et après elle a rajouté
ouf et je prierai toujours pour lui elle
me l'a glissé dans mon sac et est là
dans mon sac depuis plus de 30 ans pas
loin de 40
maintenant vos parents comment est-ce
qu'ils réagissent bah euh ils
sont il ils
réagissent ils sont contents entre
Guillet mais bon c'est sûr bon benah
Patrick il a pu sauver sa tête mais
euh mais à ce moment-là quand il est
condamné à la perpétuité vous êtes prête
à le soutenir tout le long de sa vie
absolument
perpétuité la détention de Patrick Henri
débute dans l'isolement total des des
quartiers de haute sécurité de la prison
de Chaumont transféré au centre de
détention de camp il reprend ses études
au niveau 6e passe un bac scientifique
un diplôme d'informatique et une licence
de
math petit à petit Patrick Henry l'homme
le plus détesté de France se
reconstruit à ses côtés sa
famille mais aussi une visiteuse de
prison
[Musique]
Martine ve quand rencontrez-vous Patrick
Henry en
1992 dans au centre de détention de camp
la première fois que vous le voyez vous
savez qui il est vous savez ce qu'il a
fait bien sûr bah oui parce qu'il était
même avant de le voir il était entre
guillemets célèbre malheureusement dans
le centre de détention de camp où il y
avait 420 détenus il était le Patrick
Henry il vous a déjà parlé de son crime
qu'est-ce qu'il en dit
que il a commis l'irréparable que
personne ne peut se mettre à à sa place
parce c'est quelque chose avec lequel il
vit en permanence c'est iréédiable ce
qu'il a commis il a la haine de ses
mains il m'a mis ses mains sous le nez
en me disant
que arrête d'être gentille arrête d'être
mon ami arrête d'être conciliante parce
que regarde mes mains tu as vu ce que si
un jour on avait dit que ces mains là
moi elle tuerait un enfant j'aurais dit
c'est pas vrai c'est mes mains feront
jamais ça et ce qu'il a fait ça ne vous
rebute
pas je vais vous dire quand on choisit
d'être visiteuse de prison on part du
principe qu'on n'est pas jugeant
autrement on y va
pas une amitié solide une confiance
aveugle Martin veiss n'est pas le seul
soutien de Patrick Henry en prison le
détenu est devenu responsable de
l'imprimerie c'est là qu'il a fait la
connaissance de Charles corly un
imprimeur de la région un homme franc et
généreux avec lequel il tisse des liens
et puis un jour il me demande mais
monsie cor si un jour j'étais en sortie
est-ce que vous pourriez m'embaucher et
je lui ai dit oui je vous cré un emploi
je ne sais pas où comment mais je sais
que je créai un emploi pour vous s'il
est libéré un jour Patrick Henry a
désormais emploi assuré à sa sortie
condamné à la perpétuité il est en droit
de demander une libération
conditionnelle au bout de 15
ans mais 20 ans après son crime l'homme
suscite toujours la haine toutes ces
demandes de sortie sont
refusées il commence à douter et se voit
finir sa vie derrière les
barreaux pourtant selon les psychiatres
il ne présente plus aucun danger pour la
société docteur coutono vous avez vu
Patrick Henry en prison oui tout à fait
à la fin des années
1990 alors qu'il était en deuxème
passage au Centre national d'observation
des prisons de freine et la question
était est-ce que il peut sortir ou pas
en libération conditionnelle à l'époque
pour faire très simple on a dit a priori
je me suis mouillé cet homme n'est pas
un tueur je ne vois pas retuer par
contre ce qui est éit l'essentiel de ce
qu'il voulait faire à l'époque
c'està-dire l'argent facile une
escroquerie un braquage une
affaire d'argent rapide là j'étais plus
pondéré voilà quelle était un peu
l'évaluation moi j'essaie de de
comprendre qui est l'homme
indépendamment de l'acte donc au fond il
a réfléchi sur lui-même il a il est
conscient de la chance qu'il a
eu à l'époque c'est le ministre de la
Justice qui accorde seul la liberté
conditionnelle en 2001 la loi change
c'est désormais un collège de magistrats
qui décide devant eux le détenu peut
défendre son dossier et se faire
représenter par un avocat Patrick Henry
en profite pour déposer une nouvelle
demande une demande qui aboutit enfin le
15 mai 2001 après 25 années
d'enfermement Patrick Henry est libre il
a 48
ans on éit ravi n on est allé tout de
suite à camp avec maman et mon mari tous
les on s'est retrouvé tous les quat et
tout bah oui ça on a passé vraiment des
des des bons moments et heureux comme
tout on a passé des
weekends sensationnels et tout on l'a
emmené partout
pour pour qu'il puisse bah manger des
bonnes choses revivre un
[Musique]
peu
quand j'ai pris C libération
conditionnelle je me suis
souvenu de ses dernières paroles à la
cour
d'assise Patrick Henry qui il avait
beaucoup de mal à
parler a dit en réponse une voix blanche
end encore je merci je n'aurez pas le
regrettter et c'est cet engagement là je
pense qu'il a tenu au long du quart de
siècle écoulé et c'est ça qui amené la
libération conditionnelle il a tenu sa
[Musique]
parole en liberté conditionnelle Patrick
Henry doit respecter certaines règles ne
pas quitter le territoire sans
autorisation travailler et se soumettre
à des mesures de contrôle s'il violent
ses obligations il peut retourner en
prison pour purger la fin de sa peine
perpétuité Patrick Henry le sait il n'a
pas droit à l'erreur mais l'homme veut
rattraper le temps perdu il est bien
décidé à se faire plaisir il s'achète
tout de suite un un 44 à crédit il
s'achète un scooter il s'achète une une
deuxième
voiture oui il a envie on peut le
comprendre après avoir passé 25 ans en
prison il a envie un peu de profiter de
la vie mais il est embêté parce que il a
il a pas vraiment les les moyens de le
faire profiteer de la vie et voyageer le
rêve de Patrick Henry partir au bout du
monde et découvrir le Brésil il demande
à son juge d'application des peines
l'autorisation de sortir du territoire
après tout il se dit bon je suis en
liberté certes conditionnel mais
pourquoi est-ce que moi Patrick Henry
qui est d'une certaine manière payer ma
dette à la société comme on dit pourquoi
est-ce que j'aurais pas le droit d'aller
m'amuser au carnaval de R
bon alors c'est vrai quelques mois
seulement après sa sortie c'était
évidemment assez maladroit ça aurait épé
un peu choqué donc évidemment ça demande
a été a été immédiatement
refusée Patrick Henry comprend donc
qu'il n'est pas tout à fait libre il
réalise qu'après 25 ans personne ne l'a
oublié il avait voulu louer une place de
parking à Camp quand il était sorti de
prison et que tout s'était bien passé
qu'au moment de de de de les les papiers
lorsqu'il a donné son nom la personne
qui voulait lui louer le parking s s'est
mise à hurler il lui a dit Monsieur
sortez d'ici tout de suite il a bien
compris que il était pas un homme comme
les autres un rejet que Patrick Henry
subit également au travail à
l'imprimerie corly ça se passe mal le
personnel de l'imprimerie se révolte
monsieur corly trouve une
issue espèce de
palliatif en disant ben euh vous avez
qu'à travailler chez vous on vous donne
du travail et que vous avez fini vous
ramener et cetera donc les autres
employés n'ont pas voulu euh travailler
avec lui non donc il y a eu une menace
de grève enfin bon bon pour apaiser le
le tout il se retrouve à travailler
isolé dans son
logement isolé frustré Patrick Henry
rumine son salaire de 1200 € lui semble
dérisoire il inquiète pour sa retraite
avec plus d'argent sa vie serait
meilleure il en est
sûr il décide d'écrire un livre au titre
prometteur avez-vous à le regretter en
avril 2002 il négocia un gros contrat
avec une maison d'édition parisienne il
a négocié avec l'éditeur kalalman Levi
qui en gros lui a proposé 40000 € mais
ils ont monter un deal avec avec Paris
Match et Paris Match a rajouté 50000 €
au contrat d'une certaine manre manière
pour avoir l'exclusivité et des bonnes
feuilles du livre c'est-à-dire les
meilleurs extraits et surtout et
j'imagine que c'est ça qui intéresse
match les premières photos en liberté de
Patrick Henry donc ça veut dire qu'il a
touché 90000
[Musique]
€. Patrick Henry est de nouveau sous le
feu des projecteurs et c'est lui qui l'a
choisi son livre est un flop mais son
nom est sur toutes les lèvres et sa
démarche est violemment
critiquée tu vois pas l'intérêt et pour
lui et pour la société de de produire
200 pages de de discussion sur son état
tout le monde s'en fout de Patrick Henry
avec le livre il a pas conscience qu'il
va choquer du monde il pense que il a
besoin de le faire vous avez essayé de
l' dissuader
oui je lui avais dit est-ce que tu crois
que c'est malin de faire ça et il
m'avait répondu que ça
regarder Patrick hen n'a pas fini de
choquer ni de faire parler parler de lui
le 26 juin 2002 il est arrêté pour un
vol à l'étalage dans un magasin de
bricolage il a acheté des vis des choses
comme ça et puis en c'était l'été je
crois il faisait chaud et à la sortie il
a vu un un ventilateur il a il a voulu
acheter ce ventilateur et on arrivant à
la caisse il s'est aperçu que il avait
du coup pas assez d'argent sa voiture
était garée un petit peu plus loin sur
le parking et il a dit qu'il avait la
flemme de retourner dans sa dans sa
voiture pour aller chercher de l'argent
et du coup il a il a mis dans ses poches
des petits objets pour quelques euros
quelques dizaines d'euros en espérant
passer et payer uniquement le
ventilateur et puis il y a un vigile qui
comme quoi il est peut-être pas très
très habile il y a un vigile qui voilà
qui l'a vu qui l'a surpris il s'est fait
arrêter le vol est dérisoir des outils
pour un montant de 76
€ problème Patrick Henry est toujours en
liberté conditionnel et cet écart peut
lui valoir un retour à la case prison
pourtant la justice va lui donner une
nouvelle chance le 22 août Patrick Henry
est condamné à une amende de 2000 € par
le tribunal correctionnel de camp et
échappe à la prison une chance qu'il ne
mesure pas il ressassait ça il m'a dit
vous vous rendez compte j'ai volé pour
80 € et on met une amende à 2000 € je
m'en sortirai jamais c'est quelqu'un qui
a beaucoup de mal à à faire sonmer à
coulep à mesurer vraiment euh un peu les
les les les les conneries qu'il peut
faire déçu l'imprimeur Charles corlet
menace de le renvoyer une catastrophe
pour Patrick Henry sans travail la
Commission peut le renvoyer en prison
finalement l'affaire se tasse son
employeur passe
l'éponge mais Patrick Henry va aller
plus loin beaucoup plus loin dans la
nuit du 5 au 6 octobre 2002 deux hommes
de la Guardia civile arrêtent un gros 44
du côté de Valence en Espagne ils ont
fait descendre le conducteurs ont été
étonnés parce que il était en bermuda et
en T-shirt alors qu'il faisait plutôt
frais lu ont demandé pourquoi et en fait
il le expliqué qu' juste du Maroc qui
s'était pas arrêté qu'il avait foncé
depuis Maroc l'homme est nerveux les
douers fouill la voiture dans le coffre
à la place de la roue de secours
plusieurs paquets suspects 10 kg de
hachich le conducteur c'est Patrick
Henry
après 16 mois de liberté il est de
retour derrière les
barrons c'est Patrick qui m'a appelé il
me dit t'inquiète pas t'inquiète pas
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave je suis
en Espagne je suis arrêté
et j'ai mais attends mais mais qu'est-ce
qu'il y a qu'est-ce qui se passe on
s'est on s'est quitté là 3 jours et il
me dit non non t'inquiète pas t'inquiète
pas c'est pas possible il va il va plus
jamais s'en sortir vous vous sentez
trahi par votre votre frère à ce
moment-là vous savez voyez vous me
demandez cette question là et
honnêtement j'y pense pas pas trahir
c'est c'est c'est quelque chose quand
même comme je le protège c'est votre
petit frère mais oui et quoi qu'il fasse
et oui
entendu par les autorités espagnoles
Patrick Henry explique avoir quitté la
France 10 jours plus tôt c'est au Maroc
qu'il a acheté la drogue avant de
rentrer par l'Espagne il était obsédé
par l'argent il pensait encore une fois
qu'il aurait pas de retraite qu'il
allait toujours être payé au smic et que
donc voilà le seul moyen de pouvoir se
payer des voyages une belle voiture
pourquoi pas un appartement un jour
faire un peu la fête bah c'était de
voilà il ne pourrait le faire que de
obtenir de l'argent que de de façon
illégale son arrestation fait la une des
journaux et provoque une vive polémique
fallait-il faire confiance à Patrick
Henry
pour tous ceux qui ont contribué à sa
sortie la déception est immense il a
trahi tout le monde extrêmement grave
extrêmement grave bon le meurtre qu'il
avait commis était plus honteux et celui
qui vient de commettre pour moi
le transport de drogue m'a choqué
profondément car c'est encore pour tuer
des enfants vousprenez et pour de
l'argent Charles Patrick Henry rechute
ouais vous êtes surpris quand vous
apprenez ça non mais parce que l'argent
je pense que c'est pas les stupéfiants
pour les stupéfiants c'était un moyen de
se faire vite et de façon un un stock
d'argent considérable donc je pense que
il a même pas calculé les risques si ça
se trouve où ù à un moment à force de
fréquenter quelques petits voyou dans
les prisons de camp ou d'ailleurs il
s'est vu capable de faire ça mais c'est
quand même il n'est que Patrick Henry je
veux dire il s'est fait prendre sur
l'enlèvement de l'enfant il s'est fait
prendre sur la drogue et voilà si tout
le monde l'attend au tournant un peu
comme vous comprenez que ça peut être
compliqué la vie pour lui dehors en
liberté on s'en fiche un peu je veux
dire si ça vie est compliquée ou pas je
veux dire euh il y a quelques personnes
qui sont capables de se réinsérer elles
sont pas nombreuses mais avant elles ont
fait preuve de réelle capacité de
volonté et d'aptitude à se réinsérer
Patrick Henry il ne l'a jamais
fait pour Thierry Levy son avocat depuis
l'année 2000 celui qui l'a fait sortir
de prison la problématique n'est pas
celle de la
réinsertion maître Thierry Lévy faire un
truc pareil ça n'a pas de sens quand on
est Patrick h ça aucun sens pour nous vu
de l'extérieur mais mais tout simplement
parce que nous sommes incapables de
d'éprouver de vivre ce que vit quelqu'un
qui est libre et qui a des comportements
et des réflexes que nous ne pouvons pas
imaginer et pour Patrick Henry
ce trafic de cannabis est un fait mineur
est un fait signifiant il sait bien que
c'est un risque mais il se dit que ce
risque compteenu qu'il est pris dans une
une espèce d'Ét social il doit le
prendre c'est un risque mais c'est le
risque de quelqu'un qui reste encore
vivant qui cherche à échapper à cette
espèce de mort intérieure à laquelle il
sent bien qu'il risque d'être
condamné Patrick Henry a commis deux
infractions la drogue et la violation de
sa conditionnelle en quittant le
territoire français la France demande
son extradition il refuse et demande à
être jugé est condamné en
Espagne le 16 avril 2003 il est
finalement extradé 3 mois plus tard il
comparait à
C il sait qu'il va être condamné à
peut-être quelques années de prison pour
ce faitlà est-ce qu'il imagine que sa
conditionnelle va tomber que du coup bah
il est de nouveau condamné à perpétuité
quand on a fait 25 ans de prison se dire
qu'on repart pour la perpétuité je pense
que psychologiquement c'est c'est
insoutenable on se suicide si si on se
dit
ça Patrick Henry est condamné à 4 ans de
prison et 20000 € d'amende plus grave
encore sa libération conditionnelle est
révoquée sa perpétuité court de
nouveau il est dans un état
d'effondrement pour la première fois
comme je l'ai jamais vu c'est-à-dire que
la première fois que je le revois donc
il est à valde Reuil en détention près
de rouan il est parloir il est en larme
à presque à temps plein il prend
conscience de son échec de l'échec de sa
libération conditionnelle
évidemment pour la première fois il il
parle de la honte qu'il
éprouve
euh de de pas savoir gérer sa vie
correctement pour la première fois il a
plus
d'orgueil les années passent Patrick
Henry reste en prison et rêve toujours
de liberté en 2011 maître léi dépose une
troème demande de libération après celle
de 2006 et 2007 demande rejeté comme les
précédentes chaque fois je le vois
euh descendre un peu plus profondément à
l'intérieur de cette carcasse qui se
vide de sa personnalité
et
grâce à certains peu nombreux qui
l'entourent il remonte mais il remonte
avec moins de force moins d'énergie moi
de
vitalité des refus successifs qui entam
son moral Patrick Henry doute de pouvoir
sortir un jour le 14 novembre 2011 à la
prison de Saint Mor il entame une grève
de la
fin je le voyais à ce moment-là euh très
très
fréquemment il arrivrive un stade de
dégringelade physique où j'ai commencé à
avoir peur oui ah oui oui c'est
impressionnant oui donc j'ai pas
l'habitude de ça quand même il était
vraiment désespéré
oui il était désespéré et puis en plus
euh il était déterminé
aussi ce combat contre les longues
peines d'autres l'ont mené avant lui en
2006 10 détenus de la centrale de
clairveau signent un texte percutant
quelques lignes largement reprises dans
la presse les condamnés réclament le
rétablissement de la peine de
mort assez d'hypocrisie dès lors qu'on
nous voe en réalité à une perpétuité
réelle nous préférons encore en finir
une bonne fois pour toutes que de nous
voir crever à petit feu nous les emurés
vivants à perpétuité du centre
pénitentiaire le plus sécuritaire de
France nous en appelons au
rétablissement effectif de la peine de
mort pour nous
je pense que cet appel était
légitime
que l'usage rhtorique de la comparaison
entre la peine perpétuelle la peine de
mort était également légitime et que
c'était un
moyen de faire comprendre que la peine
perpétuel part bien des
côtés était comparable à la peine de
mort et par certains côtés était pire
que la peine de
[Musique]
mort maître Leclerc quelle question de
fond soulève cet appel des détenus de
clairau la question de fond c'est celle
des longues
peines le le le problème est de savoir
comment on traite les longues peines les
longues peines on ceci de particulier
que elles devrai préparer à la
réinsertion justement et que elle ne
prépare pas la réinsertion la vérité
c'est qu'on n pas les moyens de faire
cela on n pas assez de surveillant parce
que la façon dont on TR les surveillants
n'est pas aussi très très très
supportable on en fait les gardes re
chour alors que les surveillants
aspirent à autre chose les surveillants
sont aussi un contact humain qu'on les
les mais malheureusement pour ça il en
faudrait beaucoup dans des conditions
qui sont meilleures il faudrait plus
d'argent beaucoup plus d'argent alors on
va mettre encore plus d'argent dans les
prisons le problème n'est pas de
construire plus de prisons le problème
est de mieux organiser celle que nous
avons et et et malheureusement le
problème est d'avoir une conception de
la longue peine qui prépare mieux la
réinsertion qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une
longue peine c'est combien ah je je
pense qu'il n'y ait pas d'abord la
longue peine elle est quelque chose de
subjectif la longue peine c'est ce que
ressent celui qui l'a c'est une
peine et qui désespère les gens c'est
une peine où on a pas d'espoir la longue
peine c'est la trop longue peine la
longue peine c'est c'est la peine qui
qui est qui est infligée à des gens
qui qui ne comprennent plus ce qu'il
font en prison dont on peut pas se
remettre un homme ne peut pas vivre seul
éternellement la longue peine coupe les
personnes de leur
racine combien de de compagnes sont
partis combien de d'enfants se sont
détournés de leur père pendant qu'il
était en prison combien d'amis ont
disparu alors qu'est-ce qu'il reste bah
il reste les amis qu'on a connu en
prison ou ou ceux avec lesquels on a
fait des coups
bon entre 1984 et 2004 la durée des
peines de prison a été multipliée par TR
les lois sont de plus en plus sévères
les condamnations de plus en plus
lourdes et de plus en plus
fréquentes on a en France un arsenal
législatif qui est toujours plus
répressif avec des mesures de plus en
plus dures qu'en pensez-vous de ces
mesures nous avons un code pénal
actuellement qui prévoit des peines très
lourdes on augmente toujours n'est-ce
pas la la la sanction en croyant qu'on
va réduire le Crum on n'arrête pas
d'augmenter la sanction on a supprimé la
peine de mort mais on a créé une peine
de 30 ans avant on pouvait être condamné
à un maximum de 20 ans perpétuité ou 20
ans donc vous avez cette augmentation
vous avez la peine de sûreté qui a été
mise en place78 je crois la peine de
sûreté qui est le fait que pendant une
période de prison c'est le désespoir
absolu pendant cette période le détenu
ne peut bénéficier d'aucun aménagement
de peine quel que soit son comportement
une éminemment
politique ça a été le prix à payer pour
obtenir à l'unanimité l'abolition de la
peine de mort la peine de sûré et
c'était une lâcheté parce que on pouvait
très bien se passer de ces peines de
sûreté dont on s'était passé avant et on
ne les a créé que pour remplacer le
prétend du vide créé par l'avolution de
la peine de mort en 2008 la loi va
encore plus loin c'est la rétention de
sûreté une mesure qui prévoit à l'issue
de sa peine de retenir le condamné pour
une année encore renouvelable
indéfiniment une peine après la peine je
considère que c'est une
abomination parce que tout le droit
pénal est fondé sur quelque chose qui
est une fiction ou une réalité mais
c'est le fondement du droit pénal la
responsabilité individuelle la
responsabilité individuelle c'est je
fais quelque chose je réponds je n'ai
pas fait quelque chose on n rien à
exiger de moi quand délinquant a purgé
sa peine il a
donc terminé ce qui lui a été
imposé ça lui a été imposé en
réponse au délit ou au crime qu'il a
commis et dont il assumé la
responsabilité et maintenant on lui dit
non votre responsabilité personnelle ne
nous intéresse plus ce qui nous
intéresse c'est l'opinion que les
psychiatres ont de votre personnalité et
s'ils jugent que vous êtes dangereux et
bien nous avons le droit de vous garder
en prison c'est une
abomination en Europe la France est l'un
des pays qui condamne au plus longue
peine obtenir une libération
conditionnelle est un combat long et
difficile davantage peut-être depuis
Patrick
Henry malgré l'échec hen pour vous la
libération conditionnelle reste une
vraie solution h le c'est pas la
libération conditionnelle n'est pas une
solution c'est la solution la libération
conditionnelle a été
votée au 19e siècle à la fin du 19e
siècle à la demande d'un sénateur
magnifique dont on j'ai dit assez le nom
monsieur beréranger qui a eu cette idée
de la libération conditionnelle en même
temps que celle de surci ça a fait
régresser la récidive de façon
positive nette pourquoi parce que celui
qui sort de prison avec un projet qui a
été fait dans la prison et qui est sous
la sous sous sous la contrainte de ce de
ce projet de libération conditionnelle
et quelqu'un qu'on aide à se réinsérer
d'une certaine façon et le le toutes les
les statistiques sont claires les
sorties sèches c'est-à-dire les sorties
avec la peine accomplie sans libération
conditionnelle offre plus de perspective
à la récidive quand il y a une
libération conditionnelle la réinsertion
dans la société est prévue dès ce
moment-là et et et et le le fait que
celui qui va sortir se trouve seul
désemparé sans travail et sans rien a
été organisé alors qu'il était encore en
prison la libération conditionnelle
c'est à mon avis un un élément
indispensable indispensable et ce que je
crois vraiment c'est que s'il faut
sortir de la prison les gens en
sortiront ils en sortiront un jour même
ceux qui sont condamnés à des longues
peines quelqu'un qui est condamné à 20
ans quand il a 25 ans il en sort à 45
ans bon qu'est-ce que ça peut faire
qu'il en sorte à 40 s'il ne recommence
[Musique]
pas sortir de prison en 2014 après 36
années de détention Patrick Henry
demande la grâce
présidentielle le dossier est déposé par
sa nouvelle
avocate maître de abiffort pourquoi ce
recours en grâce parce que quand je
dépose ce recours en grâce en février
2014 j'ai vraiment l'impression que
c'est tout ce qui me reste Patrick Henry
est est détenu à au CD de camp depuis
septembre
2012 ça fait un an qu'on essaie de
mettre en place une demande de
libération conditionnelle qui bouge pas
tous les recours ont été épuisés Patrick
Henry a même fait un un recours auprès
de la Cour européne des droits de
l'homme qui a été rejeté c'est peut-être
à ce moment-là en fait février 2014
notre notre dernière chance et je le
fais parce que je j'entends le garde des
saau Christian tobira qui qui dit son
aversion pour les longues peines vous
êtes plein d'espoir
oui on est toujours plein d'espoir quand
on dépose un recours en grâce toujours
et vous demandez le soutien de Robert
badinterre pourquoi parce que je me
voyais mal faire une demande de recours
en grâce pour Patrick Henry sans y
associer mon illustre confrère ça me
semblait être la moind des
choses nous allons avoir une longue
conversation téléphonique je vais
essayer de le convaincre je ne vais pas
y arriver Robert
binter va m'exposer pourquoi il en veut
à Patrick Henry de cette de cette
rechute d'avoir desservi la cause de
l'abolition la peine de mort
effectivement d'avoir desservi aussi la
cause de tous les détenu à des longues
peines qui demandent à être libéré
résultat de ce recours et bien un écop
qui va arriver aux alentours du 14
juillet vous imaginez que la date me
faisait espérer le meilleur
et le pire a été de d'ouvrir ce tcopli
et de voir trois lignes en réponse à mes
17 pages de recours me disant que mon
recours avait été étudié avec beaucoup
d'attention mais qu'il était rejeté
François Hollande a refusé
oui oui et je ne sais pas pourquoi mais
le recours les recours doiv être motivé
les rejets neont ce n'est pas une
décision de justice elle ne doit pas
être motivée manque de courage politique
mais bien sûr mais c'est une évidence
quoi
d'autre Patrick Henry ne désarme pas si
le président de la République a refusé
les magistrats eux lui donneront
peut-être une nouvelle chance Karine de
la bifffort vous avez déposé une demande
de libération conditionnelle son dossier
est solide oui il est très solide
Patrick Henry s'est bien comporté en
détention il a démontré qu'il avait
suivi une psychothérapie qu'il avait
réfléchi à sa
rechute il n'a jamais eu d'incident en
détenstion il a un projet de sortie il a
un hébergement il a je pense dans son
dossier des expertises psychiatriques et
psychologiques qui ne sont absolument
pas un obstacle à ce qu'il sorte puisque
personne ne dira qu'il est dangereux il
a entamé une véritable réflexion sur ce
qui s'est
passé je pense qu'aujourd'hui Patrick
Henry oui a un parfait dossier j'ai
envie de vous dire qu'il est encore
meilleur qu'en 2007 et en 2007 les juges
ont déjà dit
oui un dossier solide étaayé par sa
visiteuse de prison et amis qui lui
offre de sérieuses
garanties Martine V qu'avez-vous proposé
si Patrick Henry sortait demain j'ai la
chance de disposer d'un peu d'immobilier
donc un appartement ouais un T2 HM et là
vous l'aidez financièrement je l'aide
financièrement assez régulièrement oui
je me suis engagée à l'aider d'une façon
mensuelle régulière
oui pour ses proches tout est désormais
réuni pour que cesse enfin la détention
de Patrick
Henry bien sûr que j'y crois ah B tout à
fait
tout à fait il a les garanties il a il a
tout tout tout tout tout tout absolument
tout oUI NON NON son son avocate s'en
occupe bien nous on est là il y a
a il y a rien qui puisse faire qui ne
qui ne sorte pas a
honnêtement honnêtement il y a je vois
pas je vois pas ce qui ce qui viendrait
entraver cette sortie vraiment on
comprendrait plus
[Musique]
le 7 janvier 2016 le tribunal
d'application des peines accepte la
libération conditionnelle de Patrick
Henry le parquet de Melin fait
immédiatement appel de cette décision
c'est désormais à la cour d'appel de
Paris de
trancher après 40 années passé derrière
les barreaux Patrick Henri
bénéficieratil d'une nouvelle
chance réponse dans quelques jours